[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann für den
spanischen wundern darf von mir und da
sind einige unsere themen heute
evakuierungen unter zeitdruck in
afghanistan wird die rettungsmission der
westlichen staaten wohl nicht über den
31 august hinaus verlängert
mutmaßlicher giftanschlag in der uni
darmstadt sieben menschen werden durch
toxische flüssigkeiten verletzt
und bunte eröffnungsfeier ohne publikum
in tokio haben die paralympics begonnen
[Musik]
wie reagiert die welt auf das drama in
afghanistan heute gab es den
krisengipfel der g7 dazu gleich mehr es
gab auch eine dringlichkeitssitzung des
menschenrechtsrats der vereinten
nationen das vorgehen der taliban müsse
genau beobachtet werden hieß es bei der
un es gebe glaubhafte berichte über
massenexekutionen am flughafen in kabul
versuchen die menschen weiter
verzweifelt in die nähe der flugzeuge zu
kommen tim kröger berichtet die
evakuierungsmaßnahmen am flughafen von
kabul laufen auf hochtouren ein flugzeug
nach dem anderen hebt ab mit
staatsbürgern und orts kräften aber
immer noch harren menschen am flughafen
aus die es bislang nicht auf eine der
rettende maschinen geschafft haben
wir haben auch vollständige dokumente
aber alle tore sind geschlossen sie
lassen niemanden rein sondern schicken
uns von einem tor zum nächsten und so
weiter
auch die bundeswehr fliegt seit tagen
menschen aus bislang rund 4000 aber es
gibt massive kritik am vorgehen der
bundesregierung mann habe offenbar
bewusst und wissentlich menschen
zurückgelassen so der leiter des
patenschafts werks für afghanische ort
kräfte in diesen minuten werden menschen
abgelehnt an den weil sie nicht auf
listen stehen am flughafen in kabul weil
sie zu einer zeit für ein ressort
gearbeitet haben was nicht bürokratisch
erfasst ist alle anderen länder
evakuieren jetzt alle ortskräfte wir
evakuieren die die man ausgehen wählt
hat das finden wir verwerflich zudem
gibt es laut der un hochkommissarin
michelle bahceli glaubwürdige berichte
über schwere menschenrechtsverletzungen
sie beinhalten unter anderem
standrechtliche hinrichtungen von
zivilisten und mitgliedern der
afghanischen sicherheitskräfte sowie
einschränkungen der rechte von frauen
genau davor haben viele menschen angst
die am flughafen kabul auf ihre ausreise
hoffen
wie lange können wir noch menschen aus
kabul rausholen das war das große thema
heute beim krisen gipfel der g 7 staaten
eine woche noch wollen die taliban die
evakuierungen zu lassen bis zum 31
august bis dahin müsste allein
deutschland noch etwa 6000 menschen in
sicherheit bringen schätzt die
hilfsorganisation für afghanische
ortskräfte und die usa wollen sich
offenbar nicht für eine verlängerung der
frist einsetzen
der flug von kabul nach islamabad dauert
nur eine stunde aber er bedeutet
sicherheit für über 200 afghanen und
europäer die es an bord dieser
niederländischen militärmaschine
geschafft haben nur noch sieben tage
soll es die luftbrücke geben zu kurz
sagen die europäer beim video gipfel der
g 7 der sieben großen industrienationen
drängen großbritannien frankreich und
deutschland den amerikanischen
präsidenten die frist zu verlängern doch
joe biden der mächtigste mann der welt
muss dafür die taliban fragen chf chef
william burns soll persönlich nach kabul
gereist sein um mit taliban führer ghani
baradar zu verhandeln ein sprecher der
islamisten macht wenig hoffnung wir
wollen dass die amerikaner alle
ausländer bis zum 31 august evakuieren
wir sind dagegen afghanischen bürgern
die ausreise zu erlauben bei dem video
treffen habe beiden keine neuen daten
für das ende der evakuierung genannt
aber die zweifel dass es zu einer
verlängerung kommt wachsen der
amerikanische präsident hat noch mal
darauf hingewiesen dass sich die
sicherheitslage das wissen wir auch
unseren eigenen informationen am kabuler
flughafen
immer weiter auch zuspitzt oder
verschärft das heißt also die
evakuierung finden unter einem großen
anstrengungen stadt die europäer bleiben
offenbar ein weiteres mal umgehört im
weißen haus die g7 staaten konnten sich
zumindest darauf einigen die humanitäre
hilfe für flüchtlinge in afghanistan und
seinen nachbarländern zu erhöhen
claudia betzin washington alle warten
darauf dass der us präsident vor die
presse tritt und sich zu den
evakuierungen äußert was hören sie
es bislang immer noch nicht vor die
presse getreten aber auch wir hören aus
regierungskreisen dass joe biden sich
mit dem pentagon mit dem
verteidigungsministerium darauf
verständigt hat das datum 31 august zu
halten er hat immer versprochen den
amerikanern dass zu diesem datum die
us-truppen aus afghanistan abgezogen
werden außerdem gibt es befürchtungen
dass die sicherheitslage sich immer
weiter verschärft je länger der einsatz
dauert desto gefährlicher wird er für
die us truppen es gibt befürchtungen
eines terroranschlags flughafen von
kabul und wir haben es gerade gehört die
taliban lehnen eine verlängerung ab und
damit ist der spielraum für den
us-präsidenten natürlich begrenzt nun
gibt es verhandlungen auf höchster ebene
auch mit den taliban also ein eintopf
us-diplomat haben wir gerade gehört hat
mit den taliban verhandelt eine
verlängerung ist dabei nicht
herausgekommen aber nun muss es ja auch
darum gehen was für eine perspektive
haben eigentlich die menschen die dann
bis zum 31.08 nicht aus dem land
gebracht werden können das heißt es gibt
jetzt zwei dinge die joe biden unbedingt
erreichen muss das eine ist er muss
diese riesen evakuierungsaktion zu einem
erfolgreichen ende führen und er muss
ausverhandeln dass die menschen die dann
zurück bleiben eine gute perspektive
haben live aus washington claudia aber
jetzt vielen dank zur schwierigen lage
in afghanistan und den rettungsflügen
sendet das zdf ein spezial nach dieser
heute sendungen
zum thema corona seit gestern gilt
bundesweit ab einer inzidenz von 35 die
sogenannte 3g regel heißt wer in
öffentlich zugängliche räume will muss
geimpft genesen oder getestet sein das
gilt etwa für den besuch in alten und
pflegeheimen
restaurants und kinos die bundesländer
können die regeln aber auch ergänzen und
eigene wege einschlagen was die sache
nicht übersichtlicher macht elisabeth
schmidt mit dem beispiel niedersachsen
sie spielen bei der frage nach corona
beschränkungen in niedersachsen jetzt
eine große rolle alle patientinnen und
patienten die wegen cupid 19 in eine
klinik müssen fachbegriff
hospitalisierung in der regel werden die
patienten ja nicht direkt auf den
intensivstationen aufgenommen sondern
zunächst einmal auf den normalen station
behandelt sodass die neuaufnahmen in den
kliniken wiederum ein gewisser
frühindikator für die spätere belastung
der intensiv bereiche sind niedersachsen
will deshalb corona maßnahmen künftig
anhand von drei kriterien verhängen die
zahl der neuinfektionen wie gehabt die
hospitalisierung und die intensivbetten
belegung warnstufe eins wird ausgelöst
bei einem incidents wert von 35 bis 100
neuinfektionen sechs bis neun
krankenhauseinweisungen pro 100000
einwohner und einer intensivbetten
belegung von fünf bis zehn prozent die
warnstufe tritt in kraft wenn zwei der
drei kriterien erfüllt sind für die
stufen 2 und 3 gelten jeweils höhere
werte die korona beschränkungen werden
im detail noch ausgearbeitet bereits ab
warnstufe eins gilt den innenräumen aber
3g mediziner hätten sich in der
verordnung allerdings noch die impfrate
gewünscht der blick nur auf die inzidenz
und der blick nur auf die krankenhäuser
dass es sicher zu kurz gegriffen es ist
natürlich im moment eine erkrankung im
wesentlichen der umkämpften bevölkerung
alle patienten die wir auf den
intensivstation auf die normale station
haben sind umgehend die landesregierung
sieht sich dennoch als vorreiter und
will neue wege in der pandemie
bekämpfung gehen
das besondere in der niedersächsischen
regelung ist dass wir uns einen
vorschlag anschließen den alle
infektionsschutz experten aus den 16
ländern und das robert koch institut
gemeinsam unterbreitet haben wir haben
in niedersachsen das ziel dass wir zu
einem bundeseinheitlichen system kommen
klar ist die sieben tage incident als
maß aller dinge ist in niedersachsen vom
tisch
und jetzt noch der blick auf die
aktuellen corona zahlen die steigen
weiter laut robert koch institut wurden
5747 neue infektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden registriert das sind
1835 mehr als vor einer woche außerdem
kamen 42 todesfälle binnen eines tages
hinzu die sieben tage incidents liegt
aktuell bei 58
ein mutmaßlicher giftanschlag in einer
universität wer macht sowas und welches
motiv steckt dahinter an der tu
darmstadt rätseln sie noch und auch die
ermittler können noch nicht viele fragen
beantworten sieben menschen hatten unter
anderem vergiftete milch getrunken und
mussten im krankenhaus behandelt werden
die staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt wegen
des verdachts des versuchten mordes
peter theißen
großeinsatz an der tu darmstadt nachdem
sie in einer teeküche wasser und milch
getrunken hatten klagten insgesamt
sieben menschen dort über heftige
übelkeit arme und beine verfärbten sich
blau
eine dieser person hat sich
zwischenzeitlich in einem
lebensbedrohlichen zustand gefunden
mittlerweile ist er nicht mehr in
lebensbedrohlichem zustand sein zustand
ist stabil
die ermittler tappen noch im dunkeln
über täter und motiv die
staatsanwaltschaft geht aber von einem
mordversuch aus zumindest der
anfangsverdacht besteht dass diese
substanz vorsätzlich in die lebensmittel
eingebracht wurde und wir deswegen den
verdacht des versuchten mordes prüfen
inzwischen kennen die ermittler die
giftige substanz doch wie gelangte sie
in das institut für materialwissenschaft
in corona zeiten sind die gebäude
weitgehend verschlossen im prinzip haben
nur beschäftigte zugang zum gebäude und
studentische hilfskräfte die sagen eben
gewisse arbeiten im gebäude erledigen
müssen rätselraten auch bei den 25.000
studierenden
wenn es halt passiert natürlich fühlt
sich komisch an
trotzdem denke ich dass man hier
irgendwie in höhere gefahr ist als sonst
wo also ich gehe von einem einzelfall
aus ein bisschen schockiert gewesen
natürlich aber letzten endes was nun
wirklich die mensa in dem sinne und das
war ja nur ein gebäude die 40-köpfige
mordkommission erhofft sich neue
erkenntnisse durch befragung der opfer
der gift attacke einen terroristischen
hintergrund schließt sie derzeit aus
eine akute bedrohung bestehe nicht mehr
auch heute wieder bahnstreik und
kompromissbereitschaft ist weder bei der
lokführer gewerkschaft gdl noch bei der
bahn zu erkennen für die kunden bedeutet
das im fernverkehr fährt heute knapp ein
drittel der züge im nahverkehr sind es
einige mehr diese streikrunde endet in
der nacht um 2 uhr bis auf weiteres denn
wenn kein konkretes angebot kommt will
die gdl die bahn bald wieder lahm legen
und dann möglicherweise länger
sechs wochen ist sie hier die
hochwasserkatastrophe im aartal und an
der erft mindestens 180 menschen kamen
dabei ums leben
jahrhundert fluten werden solche
ereignisse oft genannt aber die
wahrscheinlichkeit dafür steigt sagt
jetzt ein internationales forschungsteam
und der zusammenhang mit dem klimawandel
sei klar und deutlich
marco
es prasselt immer häufiger und immer
heftiger in mitteleuropa das ist das
kernergebnis der jetzt vorgelegten
studie grund dafür ist die vom
menschengemachte erderwärmung denn sie
sorgt nicht nur für mehr hitze sondern
zunehmend oft extremen regen
das südwärme atmosphäre und die
atmosphäre karten mehr wasser halten um
sie wir haben wir sie das es ist in etwa
sieben prozent mehr wasser je grad dass
wir erhöhen daher müssen wir schon davon
ausgehen und uns darauf anpassen dass
wir zukünftig mehr von diesen
ereignissen haben gang die analyse zeigt
in mitteleuropa ist die regen intensität
durch den klimawandel um 3 bis 19
prozent höher als früher klimamodelle
wurden dazu mit wetterdaten abgeglichen
auch mit denen aus dem
katastrophengebiet an a und erft 90
liter pro quadratmeter am tag wurden vor
der flut dort gemessen so viel wie nie
solche katastrophen sind zwar selten
künftig werden sie aber immer
wahrscheinlicher so die studie ein
klarer auftrag auch an die zuständigen
behörden
wir hatten eben solch ein ereignis grad
in dieser region bis jetzt so nicht auf
dem zettel auch nicht in den daten wir
müssen extrem wird statistiken denke ich
neu aufstellen das wird ein punkt sein
und dann setzt sich daraus ein
kompletter bewertungs vorgang in gang
der sich letztlich auch in den
hochwasserrisikomanagement plänen auch
ausdrücken wird und dabei geht es zum
beispiel darum wie hochwassersicher
gebäude wieder aufgebaut werden und auch
wo sie stehen sollen lehren für die
zukunft damit sich bilder wie diese
möglichst nicht wiederholen
und soeben kommt diese nachricht charlie
watts ist gestorben fast von beginn an
setzte für die rolling stones am
schlagzeug er wurde 80 jahre alt
woods kam über seine leidenschaft für
amerikanischen jazz zur musik seit 1963
trommelte er für die rolling stones und
war neben mick jagger und keith richards
auf allen alben der band zu hören er war
der ruhepol der sich mit stoischem blick
im hintergrund hielt und doch zählte die
fachwelt charlie watts zu den besten
trainern überhaupt
[Musik]
wir haben flügel unter diesem motto
wurden vor wenigen stunden die
paralympics in tokio eröffnet
4400 athletinnen und athleten aus der
ganzen welt sind dabei sie dürfen wegen
corona zwar kaum die wettbewerbs orte
verlassen haben auch kein publikum und
müssen sich häufig testen lassen
trotzdem scheint ihre freude immens
stephanie schöneborn
das symbol der paralympischen spiele es
steht dafür immer in bewegung zu bleiben
zeit des wandels ist das motto es
scheint der wunsch einer ganzen welt der
hier seinen ausdruck findet die
eröffnungsfeier zeigt das wilde japan
das bunte vielfältige und inklusive
gegen korona sind auch bei den
paralympics keine zuschauer zugelassen
die euphorie schmälert das nicht auch
nicht die der deutschen fahnenträger
michael teuber und mareike müller
sehr viele verschiedene sportler wurden
involviert mit verschiedenen
behinderungen
mit den einschränkungen mit prothesen im
rollstuhl und sowohl in der show als
auch im transport der olympischen flamme
und das war eben besonders schön renault
tide ist einer von 133 deutschen
athleten mit seiner go bohrmannschaft er
hat uns handyaufnahmen geschickt ein
blick hinter die kulissen aus dem
paralympischen dorf an diesem besonderen
tag vor allem auf dem weg zur
eröffnungsfeier
[Musik]
trotz masken und corona der tag heute
gehört den 4400 athletinnen und athleten
die so hart für diesen moment trainiert
haben
morgen geht's los mit den wettkämpfen
norbert wie stehen die chancen für das
team deutschland ja in rio 2016 da gab
es damals 18 mal gold und platz sechs im
medaillenspiegel auch in tokio wollen
die sportlerinnen und sportler in die
top ten und vielleicht sogar besser
abschneiden als die deutsche
olympia-mannschaft zwei wochen zuvor
zu den favoriten zählte vor fünf jahren
nico kappel der kugelstoßer ein meter 41
groß sportlich ein riese mit
mentaltrainer matthias berg hat der
paralympics sieger von 2016 intensiv
gearbeitet
sein wettkampf in tokio hat kappel vor
allem einen wunsch
so wünsche zettel schreiben das abrufen
was ich kann das drittgrößte
sportereignis der welt nach olympia und
fußball wm mit vielen weltstars wie
markus rehn dem 860 springer die
bogenschützin sarah nehme iran und
schwimmerin jessica long usa
hoffnungen tragen einige deutsche teams
die sitzvolleyballer oder auch die
frauen im rollstuhl basketball gold
medaillengewinnerinnen in london 2012
bis übernächsten sonntag fallen
entscheidungen in 22 sportarten
die paralympics in tokio im täglichen
wechsel live zu sehen bei zdf und ard
los geht es jeden morgen um 9 uhr fünf
zur volleyball em der frauen da hat
deutschland durch den 13 0 sieg über
griechenland vorzeitig das achtelfinale
erreicht
die sprungkraft der deutschen damen ist
auch beim siegesjubel noch beeindruckend
gegen außenseiter griechenland kann sich
im angriff vor allem louisa lippmann
zeigen
während kapitänin jennifer jahns mit
ihren gefährlichen angaben zahlreiche
direkte punktgewinne
trainer felix koslowski nutzt die
gelegenheit zum intensiven durchwechseln
ohne dass sein team deshalb in unordnung
gerät mit diesem klaren 3 zu 0 gegen die
griechinnen erreicht das deutsche team
bereits vor dem letzten gruppenspiel
gegen spanien souverän das achtelfinale
das war's an sport ich dann kocht gerne
wettermäßig ist es derzeit gefühlt ihr
herbst als sommer nun kommt von norden
auch noch regen und wind die details hat
gleich katja horneffer das heute journal
um viertel vor zehn mit claus kleber
hier geht es gleich weiter mit dem zdf
spezial zu afghanistan ihnen danken wir
für das interesse und wünschen noch
einen schönen abend bis morgen wird sie
mal auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend heute morgen fiel noch etwas
regen in görlitz und auch in garmisch
partenkirchen aber bis zu den
mittagsstunden war der regen vorbei und
dann strahlte die sonne hier von
südschweden über deutschland und
frankreich bis nach spanien dichtere
wolkenfelder gibt es heute nacht
eigentlich nur am alpenrand und im
norden sonst aber ist es häufig klar und
da wird es sehr kalt uns erwarten häufig
einstellige temperaturen zwischen 9 und
3 grad in einigen mittelgebirgstälern
könnte es also für den ersten buden de
france dieses spätsommers reichen milder
bleibt die nacht am alpenrand im westen
und an den küsten verlautet aus sie bei
14 bis 10 grad die höchstwerte morgen
pendelte meist und 20 grad etwas wärmer
wird es vom mittelrhein bis zum
oberrhein mit 23 bis 25 grad der tag
wird erstmal sehr freundlich aber dann
kommen noch dichtere wolken von norden
heran und spätestens nachmittags beginnt
ist dann von nordosten her zu regnen
dazu nimmt der wind zu es ist ein
kräftiger westwind an der ostseeküste
und ein kräftiger nordwestwind an der
nordseeküste und mit diesem nordwind
wird es dann von tag zu tag immer
wechselhafte aber auch kälter am samstag
liegen die höchsttemperatur nur noch bei
13 bis 19 grad guten abend